from finland's West Coast they've been
generating nuclear power for more than
40 years for the first time anywhere in
the world they're going to bury it more
than 400 meters down in the Bedrock this
is being built to last 100
000 years it is an extraordinary time
span go back that long and it's a period
of ice and mammoths and woolly rhinos
and modern humans hadn't even set foot
in Europe but that's the kind of time
scale that's required when you're
dealing with nuclear waste robots will
pack used nuclear fuel into
double-layered metal canisters that
would be lowered down a shaft to
remotely control trucks that will then
Ferry them into the tunnels where
there'll be cocooned in water absorbent
clay experts from Britain and elsewhere
are watching finland's progress so we
have 70 years worth of waste in the UK
it's not going anywhere unless we do
something with it and we have to take
action to make sure this is managed
responsibly not just for now but for the
long term as well